are you an organ donor how much of you
are you willing to part with your heart
and lungs skin and bones cornea
genitalia why not just give away your
entire body yes this neurosurgeon says
he's close to achieving the world's
first successful body transplant most
doctors are calling this endeavor
unethical if not impossible but what if
it is possible what if you could replace
any body part without any trouble what
if you could replace your whole body
this is what if and here's what would
happen if there were no limits to organ
transplantation since the very first
successful organ transplant in 1954 the
list of body parts that you can give to
those in need has expanded significantly
almost everything from heart to hands
and eyes to intestines has been
transferred from one body to another in
2014 a mother made history by giving
birth to the first live baby from a
transplanted uterus it took decades of
research and practice to be able to pull
off such procedures and even the ones
that have become commonplace still face
complications but now neurosurgeons
Sergio canavero and Xiao Peng Ren claim
that they will soon transplant one
patients head on to a new body organ
transplants have come a long way but
swapping heads and bodies seems closer
to science fiction than anything like
real medicine
so how would it work how much would it
help you
would you even be in what operating room
a team of surgeons will prepare your
host body while in another room a
different team will be tasked with
safely removing your head your head will
be chilled to about 10 degrees to
minimize the risk of brain damage once
blood stops circulating to your head
your head will have to be drained of
blood to prevent any clots from forming
during the transition the biggest
physical obstacle to a full body
transplant will be connecting your head
to a new spinal cord at this point no
doctor has ever succeeded in
reconnecting a completely severed spinal
cord and that's because there are
millions of nerve connections that would
need to be fused together perfectly in
order to restore full functionality to
make the cleanest cut possible surgeons
will use a diamond edged blade which
should be sharp enough to cut through
the spinal cord without fraying any
nerves once that's done the next step is
to glue your head onto the new spinal
cord using polyethylene glycol which is
considered to be a fusion capable of
rapidly refusing severed neurons but so
far in animal tests this part of the
process has only restored functionality
to above 15% of the nerves in the spinal
cord so you can see why almost every
doctor who's read up on this procedure
doubts its success and we haven't even
had an identity crisis yet suppose your
head gets a new body what happens to you
we've been debating questions of
identity and consciousness for centuries
and we're nowhere near a consensus is
your identity attached to your mind or
is it all of you even if your brain
stays the same you're going to have some
new DNA if you decide to have children
your new body's genes will be passed on
so are they really your descendants it's
likely that your personality would
change too do you know about your second
brain medically it's called your enteric
nervous system and it's a bundle of
nerves in your gut that gives you well
those gut feelings 95% of serotonin
which helps regulate your emotions is
housed in your gut so with your brain
upstairs and someone else's second brain
below who would this hybrid person be
but suppose you can stomach the
existential confusion can you really be
sure that your new body will accept you
with any Oregon transplant patients are
prescribed a variety of drugs to prevent
the immune system from rejecting foreign
parts so yeah you're gonna have to hope
your new body can get along with your
head but isn't the idea of your body not
wanting to be around you just a little
bit psychologically traumatic thankfully
these questions are nothing you need to
worry about today while a full body
transplant may one day be possible we've
got other problems to solve on our way
there meeting the current demand for
organ donation is one step successfully
reconnecting the spine is another we'll
keep moving in the right direction but
if you want to jump ahead then join us
again on another what-if